here are the most common interview questions in the NHS and health sector
No. 1 what do you know about the values of our trust or hospital
this basic question is extremely popular
the interviewer is not only wanting to know that you know the values
of the hospital
they want to know if you have done any research on the hospital
before attending for the interview
No.2 how do you stay organized and manage your time
working in the medical sector can be chaotic
you can be overworked
and learning to prioritize
is key to succeeding in this high pressure environment
you need to demonstrate how you are capable of doing this
use examples from previous jobs
or even examples from your personal life
No.3 give us an example of when you have worked well in a team
healthcare is a team industry
it relies on many people working together to help deliver the best outcomes
for patients
you need to demonstrate how you are a great team player
this could be in a previous job
any sports you play
or even your time as a student
at Health Higher UK dot com we help you secure your dream health care job
visit our website for more information